one of my favorite things about video
games is stepping into a completely new
world a world of magic and wonder that
we've never seen before it's one thing
to roam the halls of Hogwarts journey
through Middle Earth or explore the vast
Landscapes of Hyrule but finding an
original game that captures that same
enchanting Essence is well
magical
[Music]
people of the internet retro tour here
I'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell and this is Kaa Bridge
of
[Music]
spirits oh man the animation looks so
good
[Music]
press L1 to
pulse kind of like a shield ability
there but also looks like that is what
lit up this
Cavern that we find ourselves in yeah
there we
go okay this is kind of oh I heard
something whoa okay so I guess it was
because we were standing on here then
that triggered that one all the way up
to the
door man I so appreciate the complete
lack of Hud
more games should do that I assume we're
going to get one at some point once we
start learning magic and have our health
meter and all that but minimal Huds how
you come way to go I sense suffering
here Spirit do you need
help you know
nothing of
suffering this is my
hope my Village
turn back spirit
guide oh here we go R1 to light attack
R2 to heavy
attack I don't even know if that's Block
it's just
my reaction after playing lies of
P
let's
see yeah I think it actually did
block oh that charges up too okay
nice Circle to dodge
okay nice I love the lock
on that feels very Souls like very Zelda
likee at the same time as
well
nice got both of them with
that okay I mean early on getting
some definite Zelda Vibes a little bit
of
Souls and then Okami as well how we're
kind of seems like we're restoring this
area I know that's not exactly what
we're
doing but man it's been so long since I
played that game Okami look at the
lighting right here oh that is
fantastic we have any Okami fans
watching this let me know in the
comments
man I originally played that game back
on the Nintendo Wii and I don't even
think I ever beat it it was a long
game
okay
interact okay so so far we've got Sprint
we've got Dodge got our lock on that's a
light That's
Heavy look at these little guys they
just
disappeared music's great too man loving
it all right it looks like they ran from
here
[Music]
somewhere is that crying or
laughing I saw him here
somewhere
where did he
[Music]
go
hi
[Music]
there
uh-oh the little one there I don't know
if they knew us or what they recognized
us L1 to interact with the rot
wisp PR oh oh wait trying to collect
hey first trophy found a
friend
hi the eyes
man what happened here little guy
[Music]
there she is run wait why are they
running from me okay there's another one
right
there number
two okay so they come in like different
shapes different
sizes oh there was another one nice is
that number
three all right so we need to collect
five to trigger something I'm not really
sure what a level
up O Okay this doesn't look good over
here let's see before we go over there
let's see if there's anything I can do
right
here CU now I
have one two does the other one come out
I thought we had
three maybe we'll only need two to
unlock oh there we go
nice
oh I think that's another one up
there
also looks like we can go across that
limb up
there I don't want to touch that area
yet let's let's see what all we can
unlock quick this way
first wait you want me to follow
you I don't want to follow you just
yet
I know for sure there are trophies
related to
Collectibles and that's where they
wanted me to follow them all right
before we do that though let's see
what's going on over
here this looks like some sort of
corruption collect more rot to purify
this dead zone okay so seems exactly
like what we were
thinking they call it a dead
zone I don't I don't have anything
arranged just yet so right now all we
have is the
staff all right so let's follow
them ooh a
[Music]
chest what do we have here another rot
nice okay the rot can now perform more
actions all right so now with five I'm
guessing we're going to be able to clear
this yeah there we go press L1 to pulse
and destroy the dead zone
heart nice okay see there we go I told
you the Okami
Vibes clearing out the
corruption now can we hop up
here
excellent oh my gosh look at him
following me now it's like
Pikmin okay so we can swim that way
or see can we grab on yes we can very
nice anything down
here want to make sure we don't miss any
chests or
anything all right looks like we have to
clear out another one
here whoa this is different enemies
frighten the rod okay they're scared and
have gone into hiding attack enemies to
build courage and combat spin courage to
perform rot
actions okay so we got
two enemies
here make that
three all right the rot are ready that
can destroy Dead Zone hearts or bind
enemies press square to quickly send
your Rod onto objects in the environment
hold L2 to aim okay this is new L2 to
aim and then press square to bind to
enemies I don't think I want to bind you
to the enemy
I want to shoot you right over
there man these hits they take quite a
bit of damage on
you probably a good thing that I chose
this difficulty
first then we can go back later and play
on the hard
one oh there's those kids
two little
kids okay use
rot they can move certain objects in the
environment dude I was just kidding with
the Pikmin comment but this is closer to
Pikmin than I thought it would be tell
the rot where to go by aiming with L2
and then pressing Square okay so they've
got it right now
now the question is where do I want them
to take this maybe
[Music]
over oh maybe right
here that is
hilarious nice okay that's definitely
where we were supposed to go I am still
curious about that we'll
see no way we I was about to say we
can't destroy those just to open up okay
all right
25 okay I do want to
see like if I drop down right
there does that take us all the way down
oh wait maybe we can just do this yeah
there we go open these right
here
see can we just open one of
them I am shocked that you can't destroy
these little things that seems like a
staple for every one of these games like
this is that another one right
there so it seems like that the rot they
will give you little
hints
they'll jump to different spots to let
you know what's going on like like like
that right there see
that okay wait use
rots oh nice now it seems that I
could if I fall back down we could use
that to come over
here maybe we're going to have to
backtrack here
shortly
okay it doesn't look like we can do
anything with those oh
man a big guy
here let me help you I can heal these
spirits and restore balance to the
forest
I know you're
kind you sense the power that flows
through this land but you do not fully
understand it
h i feel like I know that voice too
death I've heard that guy something
before all remains
here this land can be healed but you
cannot stay here Spirit you must move
on you are the one who does not
belong I will
never
abandon my
people oh
wow who are your
people
oh a
sprout press and hold L1 to
Shield okay you can just hold it down
like
that and then it just broke right there
okay so that must be what that other
meter is all
right activate your Shield at the right
moment to Parry enemy attacks no way
let's see if we can get it nice there it
is oh we were out we were out we were
out okay wait what can the rot
do they're
distracting nice all all right that was
actually a big help right
there what is
that I don't know we'll find we'll
figure that out in a
second destroy
[Music]
this
I guess they don't come in different
shapes and sizes now just the first one
all these others look the same well no I
mean when you look there they look like
slightly different sizes but yeah the
little one the first one we got it's
safe
now look s she cleared away the poison
the little guys can eat
it hey wel
it my name is
Kaa what are you two doing out here
alone in the
forest don't worry about us we've been
here a long time and take care of
ourselves I can see that you both look
very
strong do you know who that Spirit was
with the horned mask we don't know but
when he shows up the gross poison grows
stronger hey what are you doing here in
the
forest I'm searching for the sacred
Mountain Shrine can you take me
there if you want to get to the mountain
Shrine you have to help us with
something first oh of
course wouldn't have it any other way
trapped deep in the forest we need you
to help
him great idea sa that'll be easy for
her did you see what she did to that
stick guy
help us fre T and we'll take you to the
mountain
Shrine woohoo come on our village is
this
way find Taro in the forest oh we found
some more rot I guess in that in that
fight maybe that's what that
gold thing was right
there let's
proceed oh man look at that what a
gorgeous
[Music]
shot hey there we
go so that's a tutorial right there
prologue all right let's head down into
this Village and see if it's an active
Village
or if it's been overtaken by the
corruption yep definitely
overtaken there's a trophy for entering
the village for the first
time oh wow look at
this okay so I'm guessing straight ahead
is the source of all this corruption or
at least one
point oh here we go cut
scene
did it a little early there we
go oh no do we not build it up enough
to there we go right
there
another
one oh one more over
here maybe this is the last
[Music]
one that's got to be the last last one
there we
go oh wow look at
[Music]
this
the rot seem quite fond of
you they're usually timid who's this
guy something tells me you did not come
to our village looking for Forest
creatures hello spirit I seek passage to
the sacred Mountain
Shrine so he's a spirit our village is
bound to the shrine's
energy but that power faded long
ago trapped Spirits linger here Tangled
in the tragedies of our
past you must help these Spirits if you
wish to reach the mountain
Shrine on my way I met two children they
asked me to help free a boy named
Taro I'm not surprised that Benny and
Saia found you they are clever
children and would do any anything for
their
[Music]
brother we have always crafted wooden
masks to honor those who have passed
on H placed here The Masks slowly turned
to dust aiding the spirit's journey into
the next
life my father was a spirit
guide our Traditions are different but
he helped many spirits pass from this
life to to the next so you know what
happens to Spirits unable to move
on take taro's
mask it is bound to his spirit and will
help you fulfill your promise to the
children look after Benny and
siia their brother's fate will be
difficult for them to understand what
taro's
mask the spirit barrier oh this one the
blue one okay hey is that taro's mask
did zaju give it to you maybe you can
use it to open this
barrier maybe can
we
just have to get a little bit closer
apparently follow it maybe it will lead
us to
T I'm so sorry Taro I just like I have
to I have to look
around plus this game is just so
gorgeous just want to take it all
in so I
guess we're going to slow
get more masks that will allow us
to open up more of
these all right we know we're going to
be able to explore this quite a bit so
let's
just judging by the Collectibles we know
we're going to have some ample time to
explore so let's just keep going it went
through here but we can't get past
there's more of that nasty stuff
blocking the path can you get rid of it
so we can get
[Music]
through
we'll see what we can
do oh wow hold
on this guy has a shield too the rot can
purify special flowers to restore kan's
Health send your rot onto them by
pressing Square outside of combat Ken's
Health restores
automatically oh wow that was just great
timing I don't know what they're talking
about send it to this right here
maybe
nice so just have to break your Shield
whoa what is
that I don't know why I'm not parrying
I'm too worried about the shield thing
there we
go
[Music]
okay it didn't give me any health or
anything
[Music]
though maybe it's this
thing yes there it is
okay nice all right so that's probably
going to be an important mechanic to
remember
oh my goodness there's a lot of enemies
here we need
backstabs I keep circling them waiting
for the
prompt
all
right look Kana I know what that is it's
a forest
here Forest tier okay use the rot
again Forest tiers temporarily restore
the rot to their original
form use the right stick to move the
cloud in this form the rot can attack
enemies destroy barriers and clear
corruption who look what happened to the
rod he's so cute look at him which
one does he know any
trick okay there's a spin got a little
slam right there okay we can move with
them
too so wait is their original form this
like
jelly like substance
there can we do it
again oh yeah we
can so I don't see any corruption that
we're oh over here over here over here
let's go guys come on come
on nice okay there we
go and then get a big slam right here
maybe
perfect we've got more to clear here
over here Ka there's something in the
ground I bet a forest here can grow
here ooh can grow
here see that over
there we have to
Planet oh there we go right
there oh this is the one where we direct
them where to place
[Music]
it hey the Little Rock guys did it they
made another one man I tell you guys I
just love it when you can play a game
and just from very early on you can tell
how much care and passion went into a
game it is incredibly obvious with this
game
game by Ember lab how much these guys
were uh really enjoying working on
this okay
wait whoa hold on we can use them in
battle oh that's dude they are so
powerful
too let's do a slam oh I was a little
bit off with the
slam ah little too
late oh I was too early that
time they do a lot of damage though I
mean we haven't died yet but what was
that like two three hits and look at my
health I'm already planning the master
difficulty
run you guys already know oh we got to
stay out of that
too so let's let's just focus on getting
like a Parry right here oh too
late too early
apparently oh no all right hold on let's
run over here I saw a spot where we can
heal yeah oh that's a full heal that's
huge and that's an interesting
way of doing heals though I got to
say instead of it being an item which
who knows maybe we'll get access to
items eventually oh we got to we got to
do that we got to do that right
now because this is so powerful against
these
enemies even the big guy it did pretty
well
on
any more I hear
more okay so we're going to use
this that's crazy you can use it in
battle though I was not expecting that I
thought it was just going to be a a
puzzle
mechanic all right let's go Ahad and
release and see what this does right
here takes us up to 10
perfect and is there anything else we
need to clear let's talk to these
guys did you see what she did to that
monster I told you she could help
us great work Kaa let's keep going we're
getting close oh
no
whoa who is
that he's looking for them my goodness
you guys the art style in this
game I don't know if this is like their
dad or if this is taro here looking for
the the two
kids oh
man this looks rather for
boating oh the mask that's
right
[Music]
to what happened what did you see when
you put on taro's
mask Taro is here but he's forgotten who
he is we need to find three relics to
help him
remember the for is huge how do we know
where to
look maybe Mr russu can help us his
house is up
[Music]
that